[Música]
en la deutsche welle se verá obligada a
cerrar sus puertas de moscú después de
que el gobierno ruso anunciara la
retirada de la licencia y las
acreditaciones de sus periodistas a la
cadena alemana una medida criticada por
la unión europea y sotos y sin paros
esta decisión de las autoridades rusas
es inaceptable y carece de toda
justificación las autoridades rusas
vinculan su decisión y la justifican
tras el anuncio del regulador alemán de
prohibir a la cadena estatal rusa rt
deutschland operar en alemania debido a
la ausencia de una licencia válida por
lo que ésta no tiene ninguna relación
con el trabajo de deutsche welle en
rusia mientras la dirección del medio
alemán acusaba a rusia de querer
sabotear el derecho a la información
aquí en alemania todos los periodistas
de rusos pueden trabajar libremente por
lo que creo que es una reacción
exagerada y protestamos contra ella y
son sus estudiantes moscú también acusó
a berlín de limitar la libertad de
expresión y prensa ya que la nación
occidental fue la primera en prohibir la
emisión de la cadena rusa rt en su
territorio alegando incongruencias con
la licencia de operación el kremlin
prometió una respuesta espejo y lo ha
cumplido en tan solo un día aunque moscú
ha dicho tener la puerta abierta para
ponerle fin a la disputa
voy a subrayar esto una vez más si en
alemania están dispuestos a discutir
esto a encontrar una solución a esta
situación nosotros siempre estaremos
abiertos a la discusión el equipo de la
deutsche welle en rusia ya ha cesado sus
operaciones y está a la espera de una
notificación oficial para abandonar el
país en medio de las tensiones se espera
que el canciller alemán olaf scholz y
vladimir putin tengan conversaciones al
respecto en su próxima reunión el 15 de
febrero